if there's an intruder at your school
with a weapon run we as parents may
think that's the best thing to tell your
kids but according to an expert it's
really not kirsten joyce joining us now
live in studio with what we should be
telling our kids to keep them safe brian
and denise we found out a lot of good
information after connecting with a
former police captain on what kids
should be doing and what we as parents
need to reinforce so our kids are
prepared for any given situation
right now
most of us grew up with stop drop and
roll or duck and cover drills at school
we accepted these drills because our
parents reinforced that the training was
important douglas parisi says parents
need to do the same with school intruder
drills parents should be talking to
their kids about these things are normal
just your teachers have a good plan you
just need to do what your teacher says
parisi is the director of training for
safe defend he's a former police captain
with over 20 years of service he works
with schools businesses and government
institutions on crisis response planning
and threat mitigation while incidents of
any shooter on a school campus is a
parent's worst nightmare parisi says
they are rare out of the 144 thousand
schools nationwide there are roughly 15
to 20 incidents a year what we're doing
here is we're not training for something
that we think is going to happen we're
training for the possibility but we
understand the probability is extremely
low if your child does hear of a threat
at school it's important you let your
kids know they need to report it when
parents give permission to kind of you
know rat out your friends let's say it
in the worst term or to at least advise
something that's going on then the
children are more empowered to actually
report those sort of things another
important tip for parents the worst
thing that a parent can do is to tell
the kid to run if there's ever a crisis
and here's why you don't want your child
running into danger for example if an
intruder is in the school hallway they
need to barricade the door the children
of middle schools should definitely know
hey you you can help you can
participate in the barricade but most
importantly again get into that safer
corner and get your if you have a phone
on make sure that it's in airplane mode
so that nothing's gonna alert anyone to
your presence or anything like that take
these situations seriously and if it
turns out to be more than just a drill
remember police are on their way